entre bruno le maire et de general
electric le bras de fer est engagé lors
de ce premier comité de suivi
le ministre de l'économie a demandé au
géant américain de respecter ses
engagements pris lors du rachat de la
branche énergie d'alstom en 2014
bruno le maire réclame notamment que
belfort reste un centre de décision sur
les turbines à gaz 50 hertz
il exige également que jy améliore de
manière très significative son plan de
restructuration une bonne nouvelle pour
l'inter syndicale qui milite pour ces
deux revendications depuis des mois je
pense que le travail qu'on a fait avec
bercy
depuis des semaines en leur fournissant
toutes les preuves que l'accord n'était
pas respecté le fait que l'avenir du
site de belfort passe nécessairement
parce que par le fait que belfort
donation de décision a porté ses fruits
aujourd'hui la stratégie est la bonne on
espère maintenant que general electric
va revoir considérablement ce projet
pour donner des perspectives d'avenir
meilleur au soleil avec toi même
satisfaction pour damien meslot le maire
de belfort saluent le changement de ton
du ministre de l'économie mais désormais
il attend du concret les paroles de
bruno le maire sont plutôt
encourageantes
maintenant nous attendons de savoir
quelle va être la réponse de general
electric
nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est que le
plan social soit revue à la baisse
qu'on n'annonce qu'il y a des vrais
implantations de centres de décision à
belfort dans un communiqué la direction
de gee fait savoir qu'elle prend note
des demandes du ministre et qu'elle
travaille déjà sur les mesures possibles
pour adapter son projet de
réorganisation mais elle encourage les
syndicats à reprendre rapidement les
négociations avant la fin de la
procédure légale
le 21 octobre prochain